of course what they don't realize is
that they could be next because if you
endorse a system that works that way
then nobody's safe
[Music]
hello and welcome to martial matters
with me Winston Marshall at The
Spectator today I have the pleasure of
being joined by Laura dodsworth who's a
journalist political commentator author
of several books including a state of
fear how the UK government weaponized
fear during the covid-19 pandemic and
free your mind a new world of
manipulation and how to resist it which
she co-authored with Patrick Fagan Laura
thank you so much for joining me today
oh thanks for having me and you know you
also might really enjoy a state of fear
once you read it I can't wait to read it
I might ask you to to sell it to me
today
compel me to read it although I'm pretty
sure I'm going to do it straight away
anyway but let's get into free your mind
it's a wonderful book that not only sort
of paints a picture of the the web of
um propaganda instruments government
Associated and non-government
organizations mainly in the UK but also
a bit in America and then incorporating
history deep psychology
literature you
tell the reader how to deal with it how
to Shield yourself
from it and I hope I wanted to if we may
get into the the web of propaganda
because this is something I'm seeing
all over the place not only are we
seeing BBC verify various disinformation
journalists you get into some some of
this and I thought perhaps we could
start with that and and
you could talk to me a bit about the
nudge unit which is the behavioral
insights team that the cabinet office
set up and and perhaps this is also
something that you go into in a state of
fear I imagine it is but what is the
nudge unit well I'm not quite sure how
they would describe themselves they'd
have a really nice soft public friendly
sounding description on their website
I'm sure so the nudge unit is the pay
for insights team so what they do is
they work with policy makers
um to nudge people gently incline people
towards the so-called right outcomes to
make us model citizens
um and they do this many using payable
science which is Choice architecture and
nudging so these aren't supposed to be
mandates this isn't supposed to be about
um sapping fines on people or sending
some prison it's about helping us to
make choices that are better for us I
think that few people few people were
really alive to what the dangers of
their this sort of Unit were at the
beginning some people were but it's
because what they did sound is so
innocuous and so
um helpful you know helping to helping
people to quit smoking or organ donation
this is one they made organ donation
um a defaults option so you have to opt
out of it rather than opt in so what
happens where you've got more organs
available so I mean that sounds great
and
when they first came out they wrote a
document called mindspace which explains
the techniques when did they first come
out sorry oh um so it was launched in
2010 under the David Cameron unit and
the time it was wholly owned and
operated by the government and its
directors
um then it changed ownership to be one
third owned by Nesta one third owned by
the directors one-third by the cabinets
office and now it is completely owned by
Nestor so it was sold at the end of 21.
made great profit tidy profit of course
for the directors set up at taxpayer
expense it's not the first time that's
happened with a public private
partnership
um but when they first came out they
talked about how they they help us lock
up the biscuit tins you know another
thing they might do is work on Obesity
campaigns
but when they really came to my
attention was during the covid-19
pandemic because what they were doing
was helping to lock us up
um they would have been one of the units
involved in helping to make the British
public
comply with what were then completely
new draconia lockdown rules and David
Halpin
um the head of the nudge unit sat on
this scientific pandemic influenza group
for Behavior it's by B to the social
scientists advise government and I think
he's also on Sage too so he's very much
at the heart of policy making
um I mean just on him a couple of
interesting things he said in the last
few months
I tell you why he doesn't give
interviews very often he drops these
amazing clangers that give you a great
insight into how they think so one thing
he said a few months ago was that he had
actually helped Boris Johnson to realize
the virtues of wearing a face covering
and um nudging techniques on him
subliminal manipulation to a degree he
showed him a slide deck of world leaders
and they were all wearing face masks and
then they finished with a picture of
Boris Johnson not wearing a face mask so
he could have applauds himself for
having got a bad leader to do the right
thing and wear a face mask but it's
really
um also a task admission of using
subtle subtle manipulation techniques on
on a leader and you know you have to
question where the boundaries are
between
advising the government and in a sense
helping to set policy
um and another thing he said a few weeks
ago in an interview with the telegraph
was
um that it had been Justified to use
fear to frighten you know to frighten
people during covert mint and follow the
rules because if people are wrongly
calibrated this quote there's a
justification for using fear and it's
interesting language because we don't
normally talk about calibrating human
beings we normally talk about
calibrating bits of Machinery so there's
a sense that you know they've got some
power some right to Tinker with people
and calibrate them and the other I mean
the other big thing that avoids
um you know it doesn't even enter his
head is what was the evidence base yeah
or um some of the you know they're big
fans of masks which even called signals
um a lot of what they do is about
signals solidarity Conformity they're
using these biases against us and not
always on evidence yeah and one thing
that doesn't quite add up is if they are
a propaganda unit so to speak
I'm sure they won't call themselves that
they don't but their job isn't to make
policy decision then so where are they
getting their ideas from why is it why
is why has he made his decision was
Halper made his decision that masks were
good for example wouldn't the government
ask him if they have a policy they want
execute or propagated uh wouldn't they
ask that the nod unit to do the problem
getting right are they making decisions
why were they in that situation in the
first place I think it's really hard to
tell because this all happens behind
closed doors there isn't I think there's
enough transparency they don't publish
all their reports and activities so we
don't really know
um I think probably this little group
think that goes on among social
scientists who probably share a lot of
ideological and political common ground
which might not be in keeping with the
conservative party they're working with
but I I can't answer that and and I
think that's really because there's
enough transparency now they would not
call themselves propaganda unit however
Simon Ruder one of the founders of
payroll insights team wrote an article
for unheard it was a bit of a mayor
culprit actually and he did say that
he'd realize that behavioral insights
and nudge could be used for propaganda
and he said that their most egregious
stake had been the amount of fear that
they willingly conveyed upon the public
and and you write about them doing
collaboration with Skye and other
television
broadcasters to adopt a harder tutorial
bias and increase the amount and quality
of their climate coverage which is
another one of the uh focuses or topics
that they they're pushing a a narrative
a narrative on what what was what
happened there yeah I mean this is so
interesting because when we wrote this
book last year we didn't know just how
lurid and doom-mongering or the weather
reporting was going to be this summer
you know they started naming heat waves
haven't they Cerberus you know where do
you go from Cerberus if you're starting
with the hands like guard the gates of
hell what what can they call the heat
wave next summer Lucifer you know where
you where are you going to go they
should have started with something more
cozy like Rosy or Eunice or something so
yeah they've gone they're pushing
they're pushing climate catastrophe uh
very hard this summer which I imagine is
part of that softening us up to
decarbonize our lifestyles to further
Net Zero girls but that report came out
in 2021 it's called The Power of TV and
it's how to use television to encourage
people to decarbonize their Lifestyles
and there's something I think was quite
incredible about this it motivated me
along with Toby Young
um the chair of the prescription Union
to write unless your complaint to ofcom
which they didn't uphold because they're
a retrospective regulator no offense had
been committed in the writing of this
report but what they talked about are
basically was using the whole gamut of
Sky's programming from news news you
heard that right weather reports
children's programming drama
documentaries
even techniques like inserting
characters and story lines and product
placement into all of this programming
to make people aware of the extent of
climate change and what they can do
about it now we're used to propaganda
in other countries you know we think of
propaganda on TV as The Preserve maybe
of
um communist or authoritarian countries
and it's quite a surprise to see a
report published here in this country
about a unit which was owned one-third
by the government
collaborating with a licensed
broadcaster
on how to change our mind about a
subject which we're told the science is
settled but is clearly still contentious
to further a political goal because in
its areas of political goal and this is
propaganda you know that is propaganda
we saw this only last uh what last week
couple weeks ago with the Greek fires
where uh there's huge stories went out
that these this was climate change when
actually it turns out it was arsonists
the fact is that the fires by square
miles across across the world over the
last 120 years has decreased
dramatically from 1.9 million square
miles to 1.4 million square miles the
reality of that is completely hidden and
let's say a week later you get the story
oh actually it was human arsonists who
who started these fires but by that
point people have moved on for the story
so they don't see that so then you just
have the climate agenda climate
catastrophe
um narrative promulgated even more so
there are lots of techniques for at play
and we describe some of these in the
book that's one of our roots to helping
people free their mind is to describe
techniques that are used in propaganda
and nudge so one there is salience when
some very novel information is presented
to you like a big number you take notice
so you'll you'll recall that there were
predicted temperatures we've been told
that temperatures will get up to 48.
then it doesn't matter if the
temperature gets up to 48 or not the
numbers go into your head modeling so
um the number of heat related deaths was
modeled
so it made up was that on the day or
within 28 days of a hot day you
shouldn't joke but you know it's it's
modeling but it creates a big number so
you've got that big number in your head
um
everything was very visual you saw lots
of photographs and video of forest fires
I mean to to an extent it's hard I think
these days for people not to be
conspiracy theorists and inverted commas
when there are all these forest fires
that
um politicians and policy makers and
public health people say this is
undeniably caused by climate change and
then a week later
um the involvement of arsonists is
admitted but because there's a kind of a
truthiness effect
um from photographs and videos that
affect you emotionally much more than
just the written word which is why one
of our items advice in the book is to
read information rather than watch
videos if you want more dispassionately
absorb and analyze the information
because you'll get more Carried Away by
the videos
um so yeah there are a lot of techniques
that we can see at play at the moment
which are clearly designed to soften up
for Net Zero policies we we talk about
the environment in the book which isn't
to say we wanted to convey our own
position on climate change
um I don't think Patrick and I have
thought everything through ourselves I
couldn't say I know what your position
is on climate change from reading the
book but I'm really glad you think so
because we didn't want to talk about our
positional climate change or
anthropogenic climate change or what the
proposed Solutions should be I mean some
people might think this some
collaboration between the nudging and
sky is brilliant because when there are
people that do think that because they
think we should all be urged urged
towards making changes to prevent
climate catastrophe but the question is
you know if you think these ends justify
the means well you think so for future
campaigns will you think so for all
types of propaganda
we want people to recognize the
techniques that are used so they they
can arm themselves against manipulation
because it's a very current example but
it's not the only time that governments
nudge units and broadcasters are going
to collaborate to change your mind and
change Behavior one of the forms of
manipulation you mentioned in their
conspiracy theories but and as I've
already used the words really in this
conversation a few times disinformation
misinformation and another one that
keeps coming up is countering hate
speech all of this language means it's
very difficult for you to you're kind of
entrapped by the language yeah to to
overcome it and that seems like one of
the techniques to shut down debate yeah
so it's using a false binary
um a choice which is either the
information we're told is correct and is
morally virtuous or to be a questioner
so the language I think is very
deliberate so um the center for
countering digital hate for instance
we'll talk about musk in a recent story
as being you know effectively Pro hate
because if you're not anti-hate what are
you you're pro-hate so they create this
polarization there you're either with
the goodies or with the bad it's a false
dichotomy sure and um in the case of say
climate change you know if you ask
questions you are a climate change
denier and it's you know it's not hard
to see how dinar is supposed to evoke
Holocaust denial which is something we
we mustn't be guilty of so you don't put
yourself in in that camp so there's a
lot of smearing by association yeah
covert denies another one it's a direct
reference uh to
deliberately invoking the Holocaust
which is actually a pretty disgusting
thing to do I think um you mentioned
Elon musk's case against the center for
countering digital Center for counting
digital H seems to me to be one of these
organizations that would fit nicely into
your book as the picture of the web of
of uh propaganda units now the the
mosque is suing them because uh he
claims that they're making basis claims
about increased hate speech which are
harming Twitter and putting off sponsors
um and so the ccdh they have it's an
international organization and this is
being based in DC but Damien Collins who
is a Tory MP is on the board do you
think musk can win this this fight
against them or should we be concerned
about such an organization
um I don't know much about them but I've
they've come on my radar before so
the first thing to say is we've got to
be aware of false binaries even in a
story like this because things and news
are set up to polarize us
because clicks headlines they run on
emotion engagement and conflict that's
how social media works it's designed to
create engagement through debate and
anger and conflict
one one way in which researching and
writing free mind has changed because
it's made me a little bit more humble I
don't always know what the right answers
are and I think we should try and
Advance understanding between different
parties so without knowing the internet
to this case it may be that the truth
lies somewhere in the middle but you can
see how the narrative can be spun either
way so um Elon Musk can be accused of
lawfare of using his his money to squash
the David to his Goliath
um on the other hand when you look at
ccdh it's interesting what kind of
campaigns they're preoccupied with they
do seem to be quite closely aligned with
the interests of States so anti-vax and
climate change denial are two of their
big campaigns I don't see them running a
campaign to prevent misinformation in
the Realms of saying that men can't get
pregnant you know their interests often
run in particular directions so there's
that and you know they're very keen on
climate change denial being labeled or
flagged as misinformation on Facebook
now this all sounds really worthy until
you think well who's fat checking the
fact Checkers what do we know is correct
information what isn't covert is this
great case study
um that illuminates how something that
is considered a fat within a couple of
years isn't I mean there's a theory of
facts called the half-life of fats that
in any discipline what you think of as a
fat will change in its status I think in
psychology it's about seven years
so the Wuhan Lab Lake labeled absolutely
firmly by fat Checkers media and
politicians and public health scientists
as a conspiracy theory now thought to be
plausible so we have to be really
careful about being so sure that
information should be labeled as
misinformation or disinformation when
Facebook label posts that way they know
that they reduce engagement by about 85
percent ah okay so if you were to share
an article about climate change that
Facebook's climate change Resource
Center whatever it's called considers to
be misinformation it might not take it
down it might just label it as
misinformation and then you'll get a lot
less clicks so actually people that
would suggest that people believe the
fact Checkers they believe these these
groups like The ccdh yeah BBC verify
would be another one and and they
actually have a power a of course and
part of the reason for that is another
bias we talk about in the book which is
the authority bias we're we're we
naturally have a shortcut
psychologically to believe and Obey
authorities but sometimes the man behind
the curtain is not a great wizard he's
just a little man with a pair of glasses
and the um the Emperor or no clothes and
was naked our leaders can be fallible we
shouldn't always invest so much
Authority in them but it's a bias where
it's a bias that is just kind of
hardwired into us
um but similar organization the ISD in
their submission to the ISD Institute
for strategic dialogue they're in the
same kind of space as ccdh and in their
submission
um for the Online safety bill they
seemed quite rattled that a video by
Brendan O'Neill who's from spite was
viewed many more times than one by David
Attenborough and Brendan O'Neill was
talking about
um politicians at clock 26 being
Hypocrites for turning up in private
jets and you know you see people in the
space really don't like that they want
the David Attenborough video to do well
and rather than engage with why people
might be angry about hypocrisy or why
they might have skepticism and why they
might be right to be skeptical they want
to just label all this misinformation to
try to reduce engagement with it so I
don't know the internet to the ccdh case
but I have a suspicion I think a lot of
people will share or resonate people
that what they really don't like is Free
Speech because there are certain sorts
of speech they don't agree with and they
want to just turn the volume down on it
this is something I see and I've been
particularly alarmed by BBC verify and
it's it seems like on a weekly basis now
some invariably some disinformation
correspondent will
write an article calling this
information but that article itself will
include misinformation
what's your take on BBC verified do you
think it's
it can it has any value at all any Merit
I'm inherently a little bit suspicious
of any fact checking service because
nobody can escape ideological and
political bias
that goes for me too I mean obviously I
want everyone to read my book but they
should be skeptical about me too we
should be skeptical about everybody's
biases there's no such thing as
neutrality
so going back to ccdh I know that they
were involved in the counter
disinformation policy Forum that was
working with the government's counter
disinformation units
which is a very shadowy organization
that was surveilling and censoring
people for lawfully held views they say
they don't monitor political debate it's
obvious from subject access requests
that they do so I have a little bit of a
submission about these units that work
um firstly with the government to
monitor lawfully held opinions and the
free exchange of information
I think we have to be aware there's
certain people that see themselves as
part of a priest cast of Truth Hood
and I don't worship that religion I you
know to write a book like this you have
to believe that everyone should have
agency and sovereignty of their own mind
and trust people to be able to absorb
information and make of it what they
will
um
there's one example of um
BBC's approach to truth I'd like to
mention so propaganda happens in walls
was always accompanied by Propaganda and
lies part of the terrain isn't it but do
you remember a character called The
Ghost of Kiev he was a fighter pilot who
shot down an unfeasible number of
Russian planes
what's interesting about this wall the
Russia Ukraine war is it's the first
time that we're told during a war that
the propaganda is propaganda you know
the Ukrainian authorities admitted after
some weeks months that the guys took
care was fictitious
now
Phoenix being spun is a positive thing
it's like it's not an embarrassment it's
it's like this is a good kind of
propaganda exactly so it's a bit like
the sniper of Stalingrad but we're
saying during the war he's not real he's
like the Santa Claus of the Ukraine
Russia War he's giving people hope
so the BBC wrote an article about this
and they didn't call it misinformation
they did not call the ghost of Kiev
misinformation instead it was an article
justifying why myth and Legend during
war is important so I think we've
entered an age of myth information not
not misinformation it's just an
interesting plot twist in propaganda I
actually think there's something about
social media that is making us all
propagandists
we are so tolerant of lying ourselves
that we come to expect lies in general
online I mean think about your own
social media posts I I tell you what
don't you think about yours I'm not
going to pin on you I'll think about
mine yeah I was going to ask how are you
a propagandist then okay
um
if I take a selfie I post the best one
you know if I take five I post the best
one of course I do sometimes I apply a
little filter on Instagram I'm sorry
hands up I do something that Smooths the
skin a little bit maybe I'm trying not
to but I do I don't share my low moments
I don't show the days when nothing
happens or if I feel down or if I get a
knot back I share the highs the
successes the good points so in that
sense I'm My Own propagandist and I
think it's not surprising that in that
you know it's in that context that we've
got conditions like Snapchat dysmorphia
where people go to surgeons to say they
want to look like their selfie this is a
thing or even that we're in the age of
furries where people
um
believe that they can identify as the
animals the animal which you know the
ears they've stuck on themselves in in
Snapchat you know we're really blurring
the lines between fantasy and reality a
blurring which is only going to get
worse when you bring in apple goggles
and the metaverse but it's more than
that I think because we don't tolerate
truth from ourselves because social
media allows us to bend the truth it's
like a kind of a reverse story in Gray
portraits I think we're becoming more
tolerant of lies in general and so you
know you can be in a war and go yeah
sure goes to Kev made up but that's fine
it's a good thing we might be more
tolerant of Lies uh I said possibly but
it's there's a difference between
people using Instagram to post selfies
and journalists who have a
responsibility to assimilate and and
digest as much information about a story
as possible and present it including the
anomalies with as little spin as
possible obviously excluding like op-eds
the idea that BBC verify
even exists is ludicrous to me because
they're journalists so they should be
checking everything they publish as
being true or not true why do they have
then a BBC verify arm were they not
doing that already
well I think we see some more biases
coming into play here things like
motivated reasoning the my side bias
cultural mediation hypothesis so what's
cultural mediation plan well so this is
like the idea of luxury beliefs
um let me take you back to the Weimar
Republic
um doctors were
the most represented profession that
joined the Nazi party this isn't in any
way to disparage doctors they're green
people they're doing a good job but I'm
just saying that half of doctors joined
the Nazi party early and I think they
were more than there was seven times
more represented than other professions
okay
I think now there's quite an onus on
people to hold certain
um liberal views because
according to the cultural mediation
hypothesis we understand what values are
dominant and it behaves us to take them
on to absorb them so that we get on in
life basically if people appear to think
about the same then they do better
that's why you can have
um you know clearly very well to do
people living in Metropolitan centers of
world cities believing things like men
can be women and women can be men and
all wearing the same sandals
um so that's the cultural mediation
hypothesis and then according to
motivated reasoning sometimes really
clever people are capable of
um
being manipulated you know no one's no
one's invulnerable
to manipulation and the more you think
you are according to you the more
vulnerable you are to it so people who
are clever are often very good at
justifying why they hold the views they
do and using logic to justify
emotionally held belief people don't
like other people
um stepping away from the group The
Social Conformity bias we like to be
light we like to be right and we don't
some people really have a very low
tolerance for people expressing
different views and so they will find
some logic to justify this strongly held
emotional sense that they have
you actually mention this in the book
that there's a correlation people with
higher IQ Who falls short of being
exceptionally High outlier IQs are more
susceptible to brainwashing than people
with lower IQs they can be I mean there
are studies that go in different
directions but unfortunately really
clever people are absolutely brilliant
at justifying the beliefs they hold
saratha Conan Doyle was literally away
with the fairies you know this is very
intelligent man fantastic author he
believed fairies were real he conducted
supposedly scientific research into
seances probably motivated by fact he
lost his son
in the wall perhaps again it was due to
the time he was living in
um you know the adult times and maybe he
was looking for the lightness of the
Magic in life I can't tell you why I
believed in fairies but you know even
the girls that posed said it wasn't real
and they couldn't believe he believed
that this this picture of fairies was
real he was totally taken in by it and
he's an intelligent man
so we've we've looked at the nudging it
you mentioned the CDU and actually I I
interviewed Tony diver recently who was
the Telegraph reporter who uh covered
that story
um about the investigation investigative
team there to expose the CDU stuff and I
know Big Brother watch have done a bunch
of that but there's another unit that we
haven't touched on which I'd love some
insight into which is the ricu the
research information information and
Communications unit
um which is a UK government one what
what did what do you know about this
unit and how are they operating well we
don't know very much about the unit
because obviously they don't talk about
what they do publicly
um in the case of the CDU they never
answer MP's questions or freedom
information requests but the research
information and communication unit will
employ other agencies so third parties
who will then work with other agencies
like Grassroots organizations so that
sometimes the people that are creating
websites or working in Charities don't
know that there are a couple of steps
removed from the governments
um they do work like
um
prevent isasize I think was through the
research information communication unit
so it's a bit shadowy and we don't know
too much about what they do but the
problem with that of course is that it's
not accountable the government's not
accountable and there are people who are
working with the government by
separation of a degree or two and they
don't know that they're doing that okay
and they're using a model called Mind
space that's the nudging space yeah so
that's an acronym for different
psychological biases that are exploited
to make you change your behavior so the
m in mindspace would be messenger we're
more likely to do what we're told if
somebody we like and respect tells us to
do it so that would be an example would
be celebrities posting their vaccines on
Instagram their selfies when they were
being vaccinated that's an example of
using the messenger
celebrities being vaccinated on
Instagram yeah it's
so bizarre do you think that um
Sadiq Khan's mate campaign
ties into this manipulation
I saw that it's only a couple of weeks
ago and it seemed to me that they're now
trying to you know that all these
different units to police what we're
doing online now it seems like they're
trying to encourage us to police us
within our own friend groups what is do
you think that that campaign sort of
ties into what you're describing in this
this uh this sort of manipulation
absolutely I mean I've got to say
bringing the book out now during all of
the heat wave hysteria and with the mate
campaign as a bit of a gift the problem
is this campaign's happening every month
which has sneakily manipulating you I
hate the mate campaign for every first
of all he's ruined the word mate because
now am I here you think it's [__] I'm a
sheep you know that elongated word mer
it's it's it's really kind of heard like
the other thing is they elongated the
vowel and added the sharp T to get your
attention and that will remind you of
dog training Barbara Woodhouse used to
teach people to get their dog to sit by
saying sit
so it's literally treating us like
Pavlov's dogs you know here's the Bell
salivate
um
it's it's everything to do with
Behavioral Science it's an ad that
should work because it's predicated on
sound Behavioral Science principles
social Conformity the group in that
interactive ad showing you how to behave
um and then there's one Renegade who's
not behaving well who makes the
off-color smutty jokes I think the worst
thing he says because I tried to watch
the whole
cringe-worthy campaign is I'm Defoe in
the mood for some spicy breasts now I I
seriously I want to say to sidika mate
is this is this the worst you think
you've got to worry about in London
regarding crime or violence against
women that at some young lad is saying
to his friends spicy breasts is that and
anyway what that does is tap into a kind
of responsibilization so instead of
turning the lens back onto his met
police
or knife crime in London he's pointing
the finger at you what are you doing
wrong how are you talking to each other
and you're right of course it comes
straight into our living rooms you know
that ad is a group of young men in a
living room talking amongst themselves
playing video games they don't touch a
woman they don't say anything to a woman
it's just a bit of banter and it's
pretty harmless banter so far as I can
tell you know you may object that banter
but if you do object to it
and you like the sad the natural
progression is that we should be
policing each other and I think there's
something really Insidious about that I
mean it's for me it's quite um
reminiscent of the Scottish government's
hate crime bill which is probably the
most controversial piece of legislation
the governments have passed that the
government should have a say in what
what you say in your own home in the
privacy of your own hope when Sadiq does
this mate thing I'm sure you and I might
be in sort of various social media
bubbles that see a backlash against this
but and and this is kind of a question
that I think is for your whole book and
and to an audience you're trying to find
to help people not be brainwashed but is
it the case that actually a lot of
people are quite happy with
disinformation and hate speech being
tackled that they don't mind at this
censorship that they don't mind that
we're even policing each other within
our own social groups is that something
you're concerned about well I think
that's because what it is doing is
exploiting our own biases mostly against
mercilessly against us we all heard
animals we do like conforming our social
Conformity is about wanting to be liked
and wanting to be right and sometimes
that involves punishing people whose
views don't fit in and a lot of people
enjoy that of course I think that's
something that we should challenge there
are some very sound evolutionary reasons
for it but we should be aware when it's
being used against us but of course
journalists are no exception to that
um think about the the Nigel farage
Coots dossier so there were commentators
saying well it's just Nigel farage
um being debanked by a very prestigious
Bank who cares basically he's just not
wealthy enough you know they were really
reveling in that and after the dossier
came out did you see many of them say oh
we got that wrong actually this is
dangerous compiling dossiers and other
people of course what they don't realize
is that they could be next because if
you endorse a system that works that way
then nobody's safe and I mean this is a
kind of
this is a problem with people I just
keep coming back to and it's right why I
wrote through your mind after a state of
fear state of fear is very much a this
is the state we're in Burke and this is
what the state's doing to us it's quite
gloomy to observe and analyze and write
about how your own government is
manipulating using propaganda and using
fear even if it's supposedly
supposedly in your best interests during
a pandemic but then I thought well it
was it was depressing to see it to see
um this Mass evocation of fear and
compliance and people turn on each other
and snitch
Es are something like a hundred thousand
cases of neighbors reporting on their
neighbors in the first few months of
covert I forget the exact number but it
was six figures it was really serious so
it was depressing and it and I think
I've been in a bit of an existential
crisis ever since you know what does it
mean to be human what are we made of
what makes some people speak out and not
others how do we resist this
manipulation hence free your mind which
is supposed to give people agency and
offer the hope that I have because all
of the things that are used against us
are also part of our strengths and so
while though there are those who go oh
yeah they're herd animals we use that
against them in this ad you know 99
billion Burgers served or eight out of
10 cats prefer whiskers or government
propaganda at the other end of the scale
we're also fans of creativity Ingenuity
um love Faith all these good things and
that's our default that's what I believe
our default is I don't think our default
is when people rise up
um in compliance or hysteria or cruelty
that can be done to us we can go along
with it but I don't believe it's our
defaults what would you say to the
person so your audience might uh who are
who are they have an inclination that
they're being manipulated this book is
definitely for them but for the for the
person who thinks I've got nothing to
worry about this people who are against
HP show against this information I
support the climate agenda I support the
vaccines agenda I support all of this I
don't I'm I'm I've got I you know
I've I see clearly to those people why
should they re read your book well we've
been talking about the government a lot
um and propaganda and that's probably
because of some shared interests in that
terrain but this book is not about that
I mean one chapter advises people to be
skeptical of big brother and gives you
lots of reasons why so if you're not
sure if there's any basis for your
mistrust read that chapter learn about
MK Ultra for instance
um the term conspiracy theorist is used
deliberately to shut down question to
send one of our Bolder recommendations
is people should let go of their fear of
it you know it's designed to stop you
asking questions but it's really not
just about the government
um if you're concerned about online
disinformation you're probably concerned
about your relationship with your phone
you know 83 of the world has a
smartphone we pick it up up to 80 times
a day it's a wash of course it's a wash
with misinformation and disinformation
all those social media platforms are
designed to be addictive think about
Twitter it uses the slot machine effect
you know you read your Twitter and then
you're like oh I wonder if there's
anything new since I got to the bottom
you use your finger you pull down it's a
very satisfying just like slot machines
in casinos you get those colored hearts
and you get pings and dings from the
moment you wake up and then a lot of
people will Doom scroll all through
their social media before they go to bed
this is a chapter on social media
manipulation is something that's
completely inherent to human beings and
and first of all we need to get over
that you know manipulation is language
that's what we do we talk to each other
you know if I say to you at the end of
this today you know thanks for having me
have a nice day I really do mean for you
to have a nice day I'm trying to
influence you this book is about
influencing people to resist influence
but sometimes that oversteps the line
and people don't want to be unduly
influenced so whether that's the car
salesman
um or the person trying to flog you
dating videos or the course you've seen
that's supposed to improve your your
your life or even the place of worship
you go to or the music concert all of
these places use different techniques of
manipulation that it would behave you to
be aware of the other thing is the
online environment so
have you ever decided that you don't
want the cookies on a website and you go
through this incredibly long difficult
form and then at the end you you tick
the I don't want any cookies button and
you realize you didn't eat it the really
big button as I said acceptable cookies
and you're like damn I did the whole
thing and I pressed the wrong button at
the end all your online shopping or I
can give you an example I was shopping
for a dress yesterday it's a dress I
won't wear till next year but I'm
looking already having fun and I saw
that 26 people were looking at it
which is social Conformity but there are
only five left which is scarcity because
I understand these biases and how
they're built into me I can see that
this website's playing little game with
me I don't know if it's true or not
let's say that 26 people really are
looking and there's only five left maybe
I should get on and buy it but it's
trying to rush me into a decision and
then maybe you buy something online and
you think you know what the price is but
it's added something else on and then
you get to the till and another thing's
been added on that's drip pricing there
are all kinds of techniques to use
online you don't even need to know all
the techniques are we explain some of
them you need to understand the biases
they're exploiting and this is of such
concern that even the government's
investigating it the competition and
markets Authority is investigating how
online Choice architecture reduces
competition reduces your outcomes makes
pricing higher so even for the person
who thinks the government's brilliant
and there's no such thing as propaganda
and they love all the agendas we've
talked about
you should understand that your own
British government and the US government
are investigating these practices online
I also assume given the title that you
must think your mind your your own mind
Laura is is free firstly how can you be
sure that your mind is really free
secondly if it is free
when did you have your Awakening
um well I had a big Epiphany in covid
which is why I wrote a state of fear
because seeing people's fear upon
steroids by the government and seeing
people comply with laws that I never
thought I'd see in my life you know the
almost intimate rights of life being
affected you know there were men who
didn't go to the birth of their baby and
people who died alone and restricted
funerals and weddings were called off
those things as well as not sending our
children to school you know every aspect
of our life was intruded upon and I'd
never seen anything like it before I
realized my freedom was an illusion so
it really got me thinking about
psychology the nature of humanity
religion Faith politics it started a lot
for me but I don't think my mind is free
Oh No in fact by researching this book
and writing it I think my mind has
become Freer but I also accept the
impossibility of having a completely
free mind as John Dunn said no man is an
island because we're all involved in
humanity but what you can do is as an
island recognize that the waves are
going to lap at the shore
but you can separate yourself from a
continent of manipulation extending that
metaphor no I mean I thought about a
time I was scammed
um
it's kind of low level thing but do you
remember on Twitter during the first
lockdown that there was news that
Woolworths was reopening on the High
Street you wrote about this in your book
so I retweeted that instantly I didn't
look into it I didn't notice the
spelling mistake in the Tweet because it
really spoke to Nostalgia and hope you
know we were in this really depressing
time there were gloomy reports about The
High Street being massacred and you know
it brought back pick a mix the first
records I bought and some hope for the
High Street so I shared it and then I
felt like a right idiot when people were
throwing hours later look at all the
stupid people that fell for the scam so
of course
manipulation often respawn our fears and
our hopes which is why there's a chapter
in the book advising that people stop
haunting themselves because half of the
the problem is the messaging
but half of the problem is you because
it plays upon your fears your hopes your
personal emotional landmines that might
be unique to you you know that call set
out on Facebook's not going to bother
you if you've got healthy body image
um you're more likely to buy the life
insurance if you're if you're worried
about your children's Futures it's going
to play upon you so it's the work of a
lifetime and look I'm only 50 I've got
lots of life left so I've got lots of
understanding myself
um and lots of self-hunting to
relinquish but I would say that after
this book I swung too far the other way
I think I became really hyper Vigilant
about language I really noticed a lot of
linguistic techniques that people use
unconsciously you know I couldn't be on
the on hold to my bank without noticing
the nudges in the pre-record I saw
nudging and manipulation everywhere and
I've relaxed a bit from that in fact I'd
say I've got to replace one I choose
almost almost to give myself over to
manipulation I know that if I go to a
concert you know or you know Festival
being tired hungry thirsty listening to
loud music and drumming and you know is
going to put me into a more suggestible
frame of mind but I can go and do it
because I've chosen to do it and
I know how to kind of pit myself back up
afterwards are there any specific topics
that your mind was changed in the
writing of this book
um I realized how much I don't know
um so I feel as though that in the years
I've got left I've got a lot more
reading and education to do I've
realized that my social media addiction
is off the scale awful
um I am no Paragon of virtue
I have to address my social media
addiction it has made me go back to
reading on the printed page I was
kidding myself that by listening to
audiobooks I was still a great reader I
don't take it in nearly as well if you
want to absorb information you really
need the printed word it's a lot for
lots of reasons so I'm reading books
again
um
my concentration spans being shot by
social media but that said I feel like I
can use it a lot more mindfully because
I understand more about how algorithms
work how the platforms are designed not
to be neutral but to
um reflect
your own interests you know they reflect
back at you the kind of echo Chambers
you're in but also the way they
prioritize content deep prioritize
content I don't believe that those top
search results on Google are totally
impeccably neutral
um I understand how the platforms are
addictive I'm engaging with it more
mindfully and that's helpful so that's
changed me
um and it's I think probably the biggest
fundamental thing is this may be more
open-minded to religion strangely so
I've always had Faith
um but it's made me more open-minded to
adopting
adopting a code of conducts and a set of
principles our final chapter of the book
is called stand for something and the
reason for is if you don't stand for
something you'll fall for anything
look at the waves of
followership you get on Twitter you know
you see emojis swap out one after the
other
face mask and then a Ukraine flag oh
there's BLM you get the the pride
rainbow
I'm not saying that people shouldn't
follow those things so they shouldn't
indicate their support but it's almost
like you see people following the next
current thing and I think that's because
we're alive in a time of um
moral vacuum and post-religious vacuum
post-modern vacuum and so people are
adrift and they're looking for something
to hold on to so it's really important
to decide for yourself before you're
just sucked up by the next thing what
your values are so I've understood the
place of religion more which is no great
um controversial new thing it's why
people have gone to church quite
controversial in some circle yeah but
it's why people have gone to church on
the same day of the week every week
forever or they join the Boy Scouts or
they join an allotment Club because
being in a community of like-minded
people and adopting a set of principles
of one form or another is an anchor in
an uncertain world if you don't mind me
asking personal questions which you
don't have to answer but what what took
you from seeing that there's a void
we're trying to fill a void of and
that's why all these sort of
pseudo-religions are coming in as you
mentioned to that literal leap of faith
to a religion I I don't know which
religion you're referring to but
how have you made that leap oh the Jedi
one no only hitting um well I've read
quite a lot of Jung in
um the research for this book and he
talks about self-individuation so
what makes strong societies and
communities as strong individuals and
self-individuation almost sounds like a
dirty word these days like it involves
being selfish
but that's not true at all it's about
finding meaning in your life and that
can come from meaningful work not
everyone's got that luxury some people
are doing just jobs to pay the bills we
mean for work meaningful relationships
meaning in your community and meaningful
Faith or religion that said of course
religion isn't necessarily guaranteed to
save you religions can become captured
by woke ideologies too I I
if I did a bit ironic that I've had a
bit of a road to Damascus moment the
church is having a rated Devils moments
[Laughter]
I'm not saying that religion should
reflect back why I'm interested in but
it's it's changing at the moment isn't
it it's adapting to a new world
um so I think I do have quite a strong
set of morals and principles that's my
belief about myself
but realizing that people need a kind of
Crucible for Morality and values maybe
understand the value of religion and I
thought well you know I should walk the
walk at all the talk so I started going
to church
um my co-author's doing the same thing
that's not necessary to say that we've
just been baptized and confirmed and you
know embarking on a new life but we're
trying it we're both trying a lot of
things actually since writing but one
thing I've also realized the value of
what another way it's changed me is
being open-minded I'm a lot more
open-minded and I'm trying to challenge
my beliefs so I've always been a
confirmed Carnival but it's the kind of
thing where vegetarians will say oh well
if you had to kill the animal you
wouldn't do it so yeah I challenged that
this year I went to a small holding and
was trained by the farmer and how to
kill Butcher and eat a couple of birds
myself you know trying to challenge my
own assumptions I'm still a carnival
though
I'm glad to hear it
um well it's good to experiment
um well um uh it's been very interesting
hearing about this journey you've been
on and I wonder where you think it might
take you next will the next book be
about religion
well maybe in a manner of speaking um
it'll be about death I think my next
book's about death because actually I
was I was pitching a book about death to
my publisher when he asked what else was
working on and I explained I was writing
an in-depth article about the government
using fear and his ears just pricked up
and he said is this a book and he
persuaded me and it became a book
and then I really wanted to write
this book about death but I had this
urge to follow on from a state of fear
because seeing how easy it is for
everyone to be manipulated you know
including me it's not just Woolworths
there's plenty of times I've had the
um I've been hoodwinked and manipulated
I think that that's
um it's just of absolute Paramount
importance right now
if you think you know we talked before
about the states of society you know
there's a lot of books who you can read
and they really resonate and you feel
like civilizations and Decline and
democracy is going down the drain and
it's very depressing that it's only what
to do next I thought well if Society
really is in free fall everyone's got to
put their oxygen mask on you know you do
your own oxygen mask first so first of
all
understand how you're being manipulated
and after that everything is better you
know Maslow's hierarchy of needs where
he puts Food Water and Air at the bottom
I don't think that's true I think if you
have those things but you can't think
for yourself you're a Slave first before
everything is free thinking we talk a
lot about free speech and thank goodness
we do I love the work of the Free Speech
Union but what value is Free Speech if
you don't know how to think freely and
to think freely you have to understand
when other people are trying to get into
your brain and finger around and
manipulate your thinking and your
behavior so it all starts with free
thinking I think it's the basic pillar
of what we need need to do to get
everything else back on track
well on that note if listeners and
viewers concerned with people fingering
in their brains this is the book for
them uh free your mind and Laura where
can people find you uh in in in the
world in the in The Ether world in the
world of misinformation disinformation
I'm on way too much that world so on
Twitter my natural habitat I'm at Bear
reality bear is Spotlight naked not the
bear and my website's Laura
dodsworth.com and obviously I'm on
Amazon at all good bookshops Laura
dodsworth thank you so much for speaking
with me today
[Music]
thank you
foreign